هذه نظرة من الداخل لما
قد تبدو عليه حقبة ما بعد كوبان 19 في
أكثر المطارات ازدحامًا
لحركة الركاب الدولية في 2019
مطار دبي الدولي ، حيث
يتبادر إلى الذهن كلمتين للمسافر المتكرر هنا في المبنى
معقم وبعيد وفكرة
القدوم للتحقق  في غضون ساعتين تقريبًا
قبل رحلتك أصبح شيئًا من
الماضي ، على الأقل في الوقت الحالي ، يريدون
مسافرين هنا قبل ثلاث ساعات من
الإقلاع ، ما هو شعورك حيال التواجد في
الجولة الأولى هنا ، هل أنت متحمس ولكن لا
بأس ، وهذه الجماهير ليست
مريحة حقًا ولكن القفازات كذلك  ليس
مريحًا أيضًا ولكن علينا القيام بذلك
في اليوم الأول ، قالت شركة طيران الإمارات
إن الرحلات إلى لندن وميلانو
كانت ممتلئة بنسبة 30 إلى 50 في المائة اعتمادًا على
الدرجة ، ويبدو أننا
مع طاقم الطائرة من الرحلة رقم ek
zero zero one فقط.  متجهة إلى لندن ، وهي
أول بحيرة تجارية لتلك المدينة
بعد تعليق العمليات منذ ما يقرب من
شهرين على متنها ، حيث يرتدون
أقنعة واقية وأردية يمكن التخلص منها.
يتواجد موظف ated
أيضًا فقط من أجل نظافة الكابينة
بالتأكيد مختلفة تمامًا عن ذي قبل لأن
لديك كل هذه القياسات ولكن
فقط لأكون آمنًا لذلك أشعر أنه
شيء جيد فقط أن أول عمل تجاري
لحاملي التذاكر هو  تمر عبر
ماسح ضوئي حراري للتحقق من درجات الحرارة المرتفعة ،
نحن بعيدون تمامًا عن المدخل الرئيسي
هنا ، حواجز زجاجية
منفصلة عن موظفي تسجيل الوصول من العملاء ،
لا يمكن تفويت علامات التباعد الاجتماعي ،
إنها نفس الموضوع في مراقبة الجوازات
مجتمعة ، كلهم علامات مرئية لإ
ادة بنائها  ثقة الركاب ، ومن الواضح أن
طيران الإمارات أرادت الخروج في هذه
العملية من خلال أخذ إيميلي ، فهذه القيادة هي
إعطاء الثقة وإرسال رسالة قوية
إلى بقية الدولة الأخرى
وشركة الطيران هناك نحن بحاجة للبدء
ولا يمكننا الاستمرار في أن نكون في  عملية الإغلاق ،
لذلك بالنسبة لهؤلاء الركاب ، استغرق
الأمر حوالي ست ساعات من
إنذار الاستيقاظ إلى بوابة الصعود إلى الطائرة وهناك
فرق ملحوظ آخر هنا
يمكن للركاب فقط  أحضر معك حقيبة
كمبيوتر محمولًا أو حقيبة يد للأطفال أو حقيبة يد يتم
قياسها
لطيران الإمارات مع تسع وجهات
بعد كل ما كان لديها 157 قبل
انتشار الوباء فيه بداية رحلة طويلة
للعودة إلى الحياة الطبيعية جون تيفت
أرياس سي إن إن في مطار دبي الدولي
[  موسيقى]